someone needs to tell barol Big Cat
about joke world what because it's been
multiple times now that he said this on
a podcast I wish you know how the NBA
has like the offseason is almost better
sometimes than the season because of
like the drama and everything I wish we
had someone who was reporting on the
comedy scene I'm fascinated with the the
comedy world and all the comics like
friends enemies like I've always said
that if there was a woe of the comedy
world it would be incredible sh room for
comedy yeah' be like samarel saw this
guy the other night and they they had
beef he's basically describing this
channel to a tea which is why it would
be funny to let big cat know that we
exist in the paron my take comments but
all jokes aside he's brought up this
exact concept so many different times
that I'm really starting to think